this is aya and sagu too adorable
clouded leopard cubs don't be fooled by
a youthful spirit clouded leopards are
some of the most shy mysterious and
elusive cats besides their shy nature
they have a steadily declining
population making it even harder to spot
them in the wild
as far as big cats go clouded leopards
are the smallest these two little girls
will top out at around 3 feet when fully
grown native throughout Asia they live
in diverse habitats from the rain
forests of Indonesia to the foothills of
the Himalayas they pack a powerful bite
- as they have the largest canine teeth
relative to body size of any wild cat
they have short powerful legs and ankles
that convert eight backwards making them
elite climbers beyond a quickly
shrinking habitat perching remains a
huge problem as their skin claws teeth
burns and meat are all sold on the black
market this is the clouded leopard
[Music]
this is Sharda and this is Lina two
young servals these slender medium-sized
cats are native to sub-saharan Africa
and have a gorgeous golden coat with
black spots servals have the longest
legs of any cat relative to body sizes
their ears are also impressively large
and converted 180 degrees giving them a
keen sense of hearing which helps them
locate prey efficiently their long lean
and can jump up to nine feet in the air
to catch unsuspecting birds flying by
beyond birds they mostly feed on rodents
insects and reptiles servos prefer
wetlands and areas with tall grasses
near water
unfortunately degradation of these
wetlands is leaving them with less and
less space while hunting for their
prized Kerch remains a big concern this
is the serval
[Music]
this is the speaks gazelle the smallest
of the gazelle species sadly it is also
one of the most endangered they max out
at around two feet and forty pounds
their biggest feature is their nerves
which can puff up to the size of a
tennis ball when excited native to the
Horn of Africa they live in semi desert
grasslands and feed on grass herbs
shrubs and other plants in the 80s they
were one of the most abundant gazelle
species in parts of Ethiopia and Somalia
but today the eath European population
is close to extinction
while numbers in Somalia have greatly
decreased a combination of hunting
droughts and over grazing has decimated
the population this is the speakes
gazelle
[Music]
this is Tami and Lucho they're two
mandalas and this is their first date
[Music]
when at Amanda feels threatened it will
rear up on its hind legs and use its
sharp powerful claws to slash out
sometimes it can be hard to break the
ice
commando is our the smaller cousin of
the giant anteater and while both
species enjoy snacking on ants - Manju
is our excellent tree climbers while
they're larger relatives prefer to stay
firmly on the ground commanders have
excellent defense mechanisms for enemies
both large and small if a predator gets
too close the demanda will release a
powerful stinky spray four times as
strong as a skunk and it's thick coarse
fur keeps angry ants from reaching its
skin when dining in an anthill despite
these protective adaptations the term
Angelov remains it's threatened species
in the native Central and South America
habitat loss and hunting are both
looming threats this is the Tamandua
this is Zana am a cheese tree kangaroo
she's adorable isn't she but don't let
her adorableness deceive you
this rare kangaroo is extremely
threatened with curved claws and stocky
muscular limbs she's at harm in the
trees however her padded paws allow her
to fall from up to 60 feet without
injury
this marsupial is so rare it can only be
found in the mountainous rainforests of
northeastern Papua New Guinea it's a
solitary creature that spends most of
its time alone except for when there's a
baby to care for tree kangaroo Joey's
spend 18 months with their mothers
before setting out on their own oil
drilling and logging are destroying the
match's habitat and it's thick beautiful
fur has made it an attractive target for
native hunters captive breeding and
local education efforts are making
headway but its future is uncertain
this is the match's tree kangaroo
[Music]
this is wicked a red panda at 10 years
old wicked is a fully grown male with
the height of just over two feet or
slightly larger than your average house
cat as cute as he is his population has
decreased dramatically with less than
10,000 left in the wild red panda
renamed it is not closely related to the
giant panda but actually closer to the
raccoon family he loves to eat bamboo
but weren't turned down the occasional
bird insect or mammal for a snack native
to the eastern Himalayas and
southwestern China red pandas live in
trees and our nimble agile climbers
their reddish brown fur and bushy tails
camouflage them in their habitat from
predators like snow leopards besides
other animals humans pose a major threat
poaching and hunting them for their fur
the forest that they live in a shrinking
fast an estimates say that their
population has been cut in half in the
last 20 years this is the red panda
[Music]
[Music]
this is Charlotte a prehensile-tailed
porcupines with her short thick spines
she's adorably speckled but that cute
little outfit is actually an excellent
defense mechanism her spines rise up
when threatened to give a larger and
more threatening appearance Charlotte
will spend most of her life in the trees
deep in the forests of Central and South
America she feeds on bark leaves fruits
and roots her feet have long curved
clothes making her an adept climber
while prehensile-tailed porcupines are
firm it'll at protecting themselves they
are less successful against humans as
they are hunted for food in parts of
their habitat that along with a
diminishing territory have left their
population in flux this is the
prehensile-tailed porcupines
[Music]
this is Kizzy a black-and-white ruffed
lemur
she calls the rain forests of eastern
Madagascar home and unfortunately home
is disappearing black-and-white ruffed
lemurs grow up to four feet and close to
ten pounds making them one of the larger
lemur species besides making for curious
look they're extra thick fur helps
protect them from rainfall as water just
runs off it they are an all-female
dominant social group and live mostly
high in the trees where they search for
fruit to eat while they don't have many
natural predators accelerated habitat
loss from logging has left them
critically endangered this is the
black-and-white ruffed lemur
[Music]